so
let's begin with this second
day of the workshop
and uh let me introduce
leonard monsajon
from the university of lisbon and
nancy which will talk about an optimum
transport problem with bulk interface
interactions
please
thank you simone good morning everybody
so thank you also katie for the nice
organization of this beautiful event i
really wish i could be there with you
all but uh you know family reasons uh
don't allow me to do so so
sorry about that
okay uh
uh just a quick question i think i have
about 40 40 minutes right
okay
perfect all right thank you all right
um so before i jump in into the the new
optimal transport model uh let me give
you a uh some motivation
uh which is the following
so it has been known at least for 20
years now that
optimal transport geometry allows to
interpret some kind of well-known pdes
or at least the [ __ ] plant pd
as a grading flow of the entropy
with respect to these romanian geometry
this is for a continuous
space pd's and there's been recently uh
in
2018 uh 2011 and 2012 sorry
a recent progress by mass milk and chow
huang li zoo so three independent teams
uh who provided a kind of a discrete
counterpart for uh optimal transport
based analysis
and in particular this allows to
consider irreducible reversible discrete
space markov processes as brain flows
and actually uh antonio esposito alluded
to that yesterday already
so
the specific model i was interested in
in is the so-called moran process which
i will not describe
but let me just say that the modern
process is a well established discrete
model in evolutionary dynamics
meaning that's what the moran process
aims at
describing is the time evolution of a
population of fixed size n individuals
that possibly has either one of two
genes so blue or yellow in this picture
and the whole you know the whole
genetics evolves and the composition of
the system evolves according to a
specific load that i will not discuss
here
uh and what i was interested in
is that uh it is also known that in the
limits in the hydrogen hydrodynamic
limits so when the size of the
population goes to infinity at least
formally
the [ __ ] process converges to a
continuous pde which is called the
kimura pd
which is also well known in evolution
genetics
which is in terms of pde just let me
read it out loud for once uh dt raw
equals laplacian f
and then x times one minus x time rho
so x lives in the unit interval and x
describes if you wish the continuous
fraction
of
say type a gene within the population
and what is common
between these two models is that
unfortunately there are absorbing states
meaning that the model is so that so for
example here in the discrete world the
model is so that if for some reason at
the end generation you only have blue
genes
then you will remain so forever after
and if you only have yellow genes then
you also remain in this kind of
absorbing state
at the pde level it's not completely
clear but if you look at the
corresponding stochastic differential
equation
uh it turns out that the volatility in
the system is square root x one minus x
and this guy vanishes at the endpoints
of the interval which is x equals zero
and x equal one so if for some reason
your brownian stochastic motion wanders
off and hits zero or one it remains
absorbed
forever after
and this prevents from applying the this
two classical theories if you like
so and this is just because of the
absorbing states
so what this means or at least what i
tried to do for months was to kind of
come up and adapt the optimal transport
geometry in order to take into account
this kind of
bulk interface interactions because if
you'd like
the
interval 0 1 has a bulk which is the
open interval
without the boundaries
that interacts in a very specific way
with the boundaries x equals zero and x
equal one which are the two absorbing
states so just this was the motivation
however this completely fails
at least as far as my initial purpose is
concerned so i it didn't work however it
turns out that this suggested a kind of
a natural optimal transport model and
this is the model that i want to
describe today
so just a quick warning uh contrary to
the usual pd notation in my talk omega
is a compact bounded smooth domain but
omega includes the boundary so amiga if
you like is closed right the boundary of
amiga belongs to amiga
so let me briefly discuss dynamical
optimal transports and in particular uh
vasterstein distances which have been
already discussed today so i will not
recall the the static initial or
original definition of that sustained
distance
but um the problem is as follows if
you'd like you have two piles of sand
row zero row one which are two uh two
given data of the model and you want
somehow to connect them
so as to spend the least possible energy
and the way to do that is
there is a very natural way of evolving
in time a pile of sense or probability
measures which is a continuity equation
so vt here is a velocity field that
you're allowed to choose
in order to drive the time evolution of
rho
so rho is a curve in time with values in
the space of probability measures so for
all time t
rho sub t is a probability measure
and whenever you have such a pair rho v
solving the continuity equation there is
a very natural quantity to compute which
is the kinetic energy so if you think of
d rho t of x as an infinitesimal amount
of mass sitting at position x
you see here that there's one half
velocity squared times mass
okay and so this is an infinitesimal
amount of kinetic energy and then you
integrate in space and time in order to
get the overall kinetic costs
and the theorem which is due to benefit
so 20 years ago
says that if you minimize
the overall kinetic cost over all
possible transports from 0 to row one
via discontinuity equation you recover
the well-known quadratic vector time
distance or rather the squared passage
time distance
so what this does for you
it allows somehow a continuous time
interpolation between probability
measures so this picture here
i stole from a paper by uh pereira
kuturi and co-authors and the the
picture is called from a cow to a duck
to taurus because you see here i'm kind
of continuous well i am they are
actually interpolating between piles of
sands so you start from a cow you want
to go to a taurus going through a cow
so this is what the dynamical optimal
transport does
and there is one fundamental example
that you should understand if you
understand this you understood pretty
much everything in optimal transport
which is uh the case of direct delta
masses so if row zero row one or direct
deltas
the optimizer in the benefit formulation
of optimal transport is the following
so uh you interpolate the base points
between x0 and x1 which are the two
points where your direct masses are
sitting
so this is just the the linear euclidean
interpolation in the base space
and then the probability measure at time
t will be a direct delta sitting at
position x t
okay
so uh the picture looks like this uh so
you start from a direct delta at x0 and
then you move horizontally with constant
speed
from x0 to x1
this is exactly the
the optimizer in the banana bone
information
and the important feature of this
dynamical optimal transport is that
first of all it is mass conservative for
two reasons first of all because i put
zero here in the right hand side of the
continuity equation
and secondly i didn't
mention it earlier but because whenever
omega is bounded you implicitly endow
the continuity equation with a no flood
boundary condition so mass is not
allowed to escape the domain or enter
from the outer world so the total mass
is conserved
and the second feature of this optimal
transport is that it is based on
horizontal displacements you see here
that the solution is kind of a particle
that moves horizontally from x0 to x1
so this is very classical in optimum
transfer
now let me move on to a
dynamical reaction framework
so
i'm going to define a well-known
distance which is the facial route
distance between
two non-negative measures row zero row
one
so in particular row zero and row one do
not need to have same mass okay this is
important contrarily to the previous
slide on the mass conservative optimum
transport
and the official route distance is
defined how
well uh
it's very similar actually except that
instead of using continuity equations to
describe the kinematics the time
evolution of your probability measure
you use now a linear reaction ods
right so here little r
that depends on time and x and space
sorry
is your new control parameter you're so
point wise above every x you're allowed
to choose the reaction rate rt of x
and you force your probability well your
measures actually to react according to
this dynamical load
and the quantity that you wish to
minimize is again some kind of kinetic
energy so instead of having mass times
the velocity field squared you have mass
times the reaction rate squared
and the
definition or theorem is that if you
minimize this overall
kinetic
quantity
you get the squared fischer row distance
uh between row zero row one
and this is a very well known distance
it's extremely popular at least in
statistics and uh geometric information
theory because it's uh it's connected to
the fischer information metric i will
not elaborate on this but it's it's also
a very well-known distance
and uh let me go through very quickly
the very same fundamental example which
is again the two direct delta masses so
one at x0 and one and x1
and it turns out that the fisheries
distance is now um
if you wish linear interpolation between
the square roots
so what happens is that you start from
the direct delta at x0 and instead of
displacing the mass from x0 to x1
continuously in space what you do is
that you decrease the mass at x0 while
increasing the mass at x1
right
so two features again here the first one
is that this is not mass conservative
and in particular as i already said
row zero and row one can have different
masses
and the second feature is that rather
than horizontal displacements this is
now based on vertical displacements or
vertical reaction
death and birth if you wish
so these are two well-known
frameworks dynamical optimal transport
horizontal displacements and dynamical
reaction vertical reaction and healing
of mass
so the next step i want to talk about is
somehow a mixture of those two processes
and this gives rise to the so-called
unbalanced optimal transport which was
developed recently
so
uh the key word here is vasserstein
fisher rao i should also mention since
jose pesavade is in the audience uh also
this is also known as the hellinger
kantorovich distance
so the definition theorem is as follows
and it's a very natural variation on the
previous two frameworks
the key the kinematics you want to use
now in order to connect two arbitrary
positive measures row zero one is
well you mix two processes horizontal
displacements according to a velocity
field v that you're allowed to choose
and a vertical reaction according to
reaction rates r that you're also
allowed to choose so now you have two
control parameters the velocity field to
displace mass horizontally and the
reaction rate r to kind of kill or
create mass locally
and what you emphasize is just the sum
of the previous two kinematic costs
and the theorem is that uh this defines
the square of a distance so the
vasterschlein feature route distance for
the obvious reasons
and it turns out that this is a nice
distance with lots of interesting
properties on the set of non-negative
hubble measures
and this was developed well now five
years ago so by chondrative myself and
vorotnikov
so this is what i call the portuguese
teams
liero milk
so giuseppe is in the audience and the
third team that also came up
independently with the same uh construct
is uh the paris team so shiza perez
and uh really the three three prince
came out within three months of time so
it's just simultaneously everything
popped up
and one way to describe very informally
this vasserstein fisheries setting is
that this kind of geometry is some kind
of informal convolution between
horizontal vaser stein and vertical
fissura
right
one thing i should mention here is that
you can use a weight parameter kappa so
kappa here is a parameter in the model
that the user can choose freely and it
measures the relative importance of
reaction versus transport in some sense
and this will be important later on
oh by the way if there's any questions
please do interrupt at any time
okay so just a quick a very brief slide
on the convex analysis it's mostly
notational convection
so let me remind here the
kinematic continuity equation with
reaction that i described earlier and
this here is the the kinetic costs uh to
be infamized in the vassaline fischerau
construction
it turns out that the primary variables
which are the mass rho the velocity v
and the reaction rate r
are not really the right variables to
use the right variables to use are the
so-called mass momentum variables
which are here rho g and f
which is if you'd like a physicist will
call these momentum uh so rho v mass
times velocity is indeed momentum so rho
v here is if you'd like a horizontal
momentum characterizing horizontal
displacement of particles whereas here
rho r is a vertical momentum
characterizing reaction birth death
creation of particles if you like
and if you do the computation if you
express the lagrangian action here
in terms of these new variables rho g
and little f
it turns out yeah you can express this
very simply as
this quotient here
and this question
has the good taste of being
jointly convex as a function of rho
capital g and little f and one
homogeneous
and this is exactly what you need to
extend
a functional from functions to measures
right one homogeneity is exactly what
you need to define functions over
measures
so now i'm just reformulating the
previous
setting
so what i'm my control parameters are
now momentum capital g
source little f
and the kinetic action to be
minimized is now this new
reformulation of the previous one okay
this is just a convenience because i'm
not going to talk about velocity and
reaction anymore i will only use the
momentum variables
okay
so uh
let me now come to the the the real
business which is a bulk interface
because this is the title of my talk so
if you if you recall that the very first
slide was an introduction and i want to
come up with an optimal transport that
somehow
distinguishes uh displacement in the
interior displacement on the boundary of
my domain and kind of
allows both to interact with one another
and it will help at least for for me
personally it really helped to think of
this as a c
so
here is a completely randomly chosen
city right so you guys should be here in
the simons institute
and very often uh in cities
so uh there's downtown very with a very
dense uh network of very small narrow
roads where you cannot drive too fast
and then
there's a circular
highway surrounding the city that
facilitates very fast displacement of
cars i actually had to look up the word
in english apparently it's called a ring
road
so that's what it is
so what i want to think now is of
downtown the city
capital omega
as the bulk of my domain
and its boundary which i will from now
on denote as
capital gamma
as a ring road surrounding the sea
and the model i want to come up with
should include three main ingredients
the first one is
transport of cars in the city
the second one is transport of cars
along the fast highway
and the third ingredient is that
you know cars should be able to move
from the city to the highway or vice
versa exit the highway to enter back to
the city
but this should require to pay a toll so
i don't know about the u.s but at least
in europe or at least in most countries
in europe
you have to pay something you have to
pay a toll to enter highways
right so just for symmetry here i'm
imposing in the model that you should
pay a toll to enter the highway but also
to get off the highway which is
you know disputable as a modeling
assumption but for the mathematics uh
perspective this is completely fine
so
this is the somehow the rough idea so
now let me try to you know put this on
more solid the ground and so here's the
setup
so
i i will think from now on as little
omega
as the density of blue cars
in the city so downtown
and little gamma will be the density of
cars that are on the highway and are
possibly allowed to drive fast okay and
i will keep distinguished two distinct
colors so the blue cars drive in the
city and the red cars drive on the road
and my space
will be this guy here so what i denote
by p plus of omega
will be the set of pairs
omega gamma
of positive measures on the city and on
the road respectively
such that the total mass is one
okay
so
obviously here p stands for probability
measure in the sense that i have a
normalization on the total quantity of
cars
and the plus here is just to remind that
the total quantity is not just the total
quantity of cars in the city or on the
road but it's the combined quantity the
overall quantity of cars
so from now on whenever you hear me
speaking of
probability measures most likely it will
be actually in this sense of extended
you know pairs of measures such that
they sum up to one okay
so this will be the the space of
measures on which i'm going to define
the distance
and the distance is defined as follows
so i i called it the rainbow distance
so uh here
you have
the displacement of blue cars in the c
so dt little omega plus divergence of a
flux capital f equals zero which means
that particle in the blue in the blue in
the blue city drive according to capital
f
the red cars now
do something else
so first of all they're allowed to drive
on the road according to this capital g
field so this divergence here is an
intrinsic if you'd like a romanian d
minus one uh dimensional divergence on
the on the
on the manifolds which is the boundary
of my domain
but in addition to driving
they can also somehow appear so little f
here appears as an influx of cars
and roughly speaking you can think of
little f as the cars that are actually
exiting the city and entering the
highway
so if you're sitting on the highway
possibly what you see is an influx of
cars coming from the city right
and uh the two uh
the two sets so the cd and red are
coupled through the constraints
that
the outflux
of the momentum capital f in the city
should match the influx little f
of cars on the road
so if you'd like this is the total
conservation of mass meaning that if i'm
a blue car i'm driving in the city
freely then eventually i reach the
highway but actually i don't reach the
highway when i reach the highway
presumably i stop i pay the toll
and once i'm
i have paid the toll and i'm just on the
other side of the barrier then i change
color i don't disappear right out of out
of nowhere i just become a red car right
so i i use colors to distinguish cars
that are possibly not paying the toll
yet
from those the red ones that already
have paid the bill okay
and by doing so the total quantity of
mass is conserved
and the cost that i'm minimizing is a
very natural cost which is here the blue
cars has a purely kinetic cost so the
only thing that matters is
when you're driving the city how fast
you're driving in some sense
and as far as those red cars are
concerned there's a pure kinematic cost
which is a velocity squared or momentum
squared on the road but also
this guy here which is the squared of
the influx
analyzed by kappa
so kappa the parameter kappa which is
fixed here
encodes how expensive it is to go from
the city to the highway it's actually a
dollar price how much it costs
to you know it's the total fee
and the theorem is as follows so if you
minimize this overall lagrangian over
all such pairs of continuity equations
you define the square of a distance
on this extended well on this
probability space which let me remind
you once more is actually the space of
pairs of measures little omega and
little gamma
okay
and of course
built in my model there's the total
conservation of mass meaning that this
row calligraphic which is just the sum
of those two measures
always integrates to one in the whole
domain
so maybe a few quick comments the first
one is that uh
the model is only actually coupled or
the two worlds if you like the city and
the road are only coupled through this
flux condition
the second thing which is not clear here
because i didn't write down carefully
the precise weak formulations but the
thing is the weak formulation is so weak
that you can actually allow
for little f non-zero
even though capital f is zero
which seems weird because if i'm
enforcing uh that little f should be the
flux of capital f if capital f is zero
then little f should also be zero
however uh you can understand this
apparent paradox as follows
so this is kind of a think of chemistry
this is a local stoichiometry
think of a blue car so you're sitting in
your blue car you're driving the city
and then you arrive just just at the
boundary of the city which is the tall
area
so you stop
and you stop just in front of the
barrier
but as long as you haven't paid the fee
you're still in the tall area but you're
on one side of the barrier
then you pay the fee and what you do is
actually you're virtually on the other
side of the barrier suddenly right but
as far as the space variable is
concerned you're still sitting on the
very same spot you just change color
depending on whether or not you've paid
the top fee
and that's exactly what this
weak formulation allows to do right so
it's not just a magic mambo dumbo it's
really it's built in it's stoichiometry
it's chemistry if you like
all right so let me give you a very
sketchy proof of at least why this
quantity is always finite
so let me remind you the the kinematics
that you're allowed to choose in order
to drive your system so the control
parameters are capital f
capital g and little f right
and so here is the typical situation you
have like blue cars maybe inside the
city blue cars are actually also allowed
to be on the boundary
let me remind you that my domain capital
omega is closed and compact so the
boundary of capital omega
belongs to amiga and therefore the blue
measures are also allowed to charge the
boundary right
so here is a typical situation
and uh what i can do first is as a first
step is use pure optimum transport
inside the city so i'm not moving the
red cars around i'm just you know
driving the blue cars
and uh more precisely let me pick any
arbitrary
point x star on the boundary
and then what i can do is bring all the
blue cars to this position x star
right
so
here's what happens all the blue cars
kind of moved in an optimal way
presumably uh to the blue point so the
blue measure is just a direct delta
concentrated at this position x star
now as a second step what i can do is i
can use a pure vassar strength transport
along the road only meaning that now
blue cars don't move they stay put at
position x star and only the red cars
will be driven
along the road
and i didn't mention it but of course
there's a well-developed theory of
optimal transport on manifolds so
whatever i can do on a boundary
euclidean domain i can do on a manifold
and uh if i view the road as a d minus
one dimensional manifold i can do
classical optimal transport on this
magnet
so this is what these arrows mean
and in particular all the red mass you
can bring back to exactly the same
position
with the finite cost
so what happens now is that you have
blue cars red cars sitting at the same
position except that
you know they're not on the same side of
the barrier the blue cars have not
played the tool the red ones have
and the last step is well now you can
guess i'm going to use pure reaction so
pure fisher row reaction
in order to do some kind of transform
blue cars into red cars
and this has a cost they should pay the
top to do so right but you can do it
with a finite cost
and what happens is that in the end all
the blue cars are simply staying boots
but they do you know they change color
they pay the fee and therefore they
change colors
and this also has a finite cost
so overall what we did is that uh we
connected via these admissible processes
which are here transports on the city
transport on the road
and the reaction i connected an
arbitrary pair row zero omega zero to
this particular point
which is a row star with
no blue cars here so there's nothing in
the cd anymore and all the mass is now
concentrated on red cars at position x
star
so by symmetry of course if i connected
row zero to this particular real star
with finite cost i can now transport
real star to any other arbitrary row one
with finite cost and therefore i can
join row zero to row one with final cost
right
this of course is far from being optimal
the optimal transport between row zero
and row one will most likely not be
looking like that of course but at least
i'm guaranteed that it has a final bus
okay so uh i want just to give you a
hint uh about duality
uh and one thing i i don't want to go
too much into is the proof of existence
of minimizers in my uh you know
optimization problem defining my my
squared ring row distance but
this is heavily based on convex analysis
and more precisely on von neumann min
max theorem
so symbolically
a is my kinetic action involving the
momentum
on the city on the road and the flux
and formally uh the infirmization
problem i have is that i want to
minimize of repairs omega gamma
which are linearly constrained
in order to satisfy the two independent
continuing education so one for omega
one for gamma
so i have a linear constraint and i want
to minimize a convex action
right
so uh the first step you can do is
you use lagrange multiplier fipsy
in order to encode the linear
constraints on your primal variables
omega gamma and you encode these
constraints using an auxiliary pair of
lagrange multipliers heaps
and now you have insult
of a functional which is
convex
in the omega gamma variables and linear
in the fipsy
variables
and this is precisely the the framework
of where you can apply the von neumann
min max theorem and the von minema von
neumann min max theorem allows you to
exchange in soup equals soup
okay
this requires some technical work
because everything here of course is
infinite dimensional but it's actually
very straightforward
and so in my context now of my you know
specific bulk interaction model that i
just described if you go carefully
through this uh you know duality in soup
equal soup construction what you get is
the following
uh so this is a duality with hamilton
jacobi sub solutions
so the result is as follows
the square distance between row zero row
one can be recovered as
the supreme over fipsy which are c1
function depending on time and space
the quantity to maximize is this linear
integral
and what you do is you impromise over
all pairs fipsy
which are sub-solution of this coupled
system of hamilton jacobi equations
so for you know for practitioners of
optimal transport this is extremely
natural to look into this is actually
very similar to a classical results
which is of course duality with the
hamilton jacobi sub solutions in optimal
transport the only thing i want to point
out for specialists in the audience is
that the coupling here is maybe not so
completely standard because
fee
lives
in omega so on the roads
whereas c
leaves on the boundary here so you see
that the boundary the hamilton jacobi
equation on the boundary
sees the trace
of the
the multiplier fee
which is defined on the interior okay
so i'm not going to give you the proof
of that
however what i want to discuss very
briefly is a very neat corollary
which is the following so if you fix the
end points rho 0 rho 1
the distance as a function of the total
parameter kappa
is monotony increasing in cap which
seems kind of reasonable right the more
expensive the toffee is the more
difficult it is to move mass from from
the city to the highway so it seems very
reasonable however if you look at the
primal formulation it's not completely
clear the adventure the advantage of
this duality formulation so this
proposition here of mine uh is that now
the proof is very obvious so let me go
through the proof it's one line
it suffices to notice that the set of
solutions
s kappa
is decreasing in kappa
meaning that if you have a
a pair of sub solution flip c for a
given value of kappa here
then the very same pair fipsy is also a
sub solution for smaller values
of kappa
or kappa prime if you'd like
so
this means that the set of sub solutions
is monotony increasing for the inclusion
and when you take the soup over larger
sets you increase the value of the soup
right
and that's it that's
end of proof
so
this being said uh this duality with
hamilton jacobi equation suggests even
more
so here i'm just uh recalling the the
formulation the the dual uh formulation
in terms of hammer conjunct will be uh
solutions and it turns out think for a
second that phi 0 and v1 and c0 sorry
are given to you
if you want to increase this quantity as
much as possible in order to get the
soup
what you want to do is take c1 and c1 as
large as possible right because all my
measures here are positive or
non-negative so you want to take c1 and
c1 as large as possible however ph and c
are constrained to be sub-solutions
so the only possibility to increase two
sub solutions as much as possible is
actually to saturate inequalities and
instead of taking sub solutions you take
solutions
right
and the result is the following it's a
certification theorem which says that if
you can find
a pair of potentials fipsy
that are actually solving the hamilton
jacobi equations and not sub solutions
anymore
then the corresponding pair of measures
rho omega are guaranteed to be
minimizers
so in other words they are going to be
minimizing geodesics between your
endpoints
and what this allows to do is two things
first of all
if you have a good guess of what the
answers or what the you know the
interpolating geodesics should be or you
believe should be then this theorem
allows you to check or to guarantee that
actually your hands is a good entrance
and the second one is that this gives a
reminder structure in the spirit of
otto's work on the porsche media
equation
um
so i will come back to this later on but
one thing i want to address is the
question about 1.06 because in classical
uh optimum transport there's a nice
duality which is uh the duality between
ellarian and lagrangian particles
so one way to formulate this is that
if you were to compute the squared
versus distance between two direct
deltas at x0 and x1 the result is that
this is exactly the euclidean distance
between the base points x0 and x1 and we
actually we saw an example of that when
i described the
interpolating geodesics between these
two direct deltas
so in some sense there's a one-to-one
correspondence between uh minimizing
vassal shan geodesics and constant speed
particles in the lagrangian world
so the natural question now to ask is
what can i say in my you know in my
extended model so now i have you know
blue cars red cars uh can i connect
one
car
sitting inside the cd at x0 to one car
sitting on the boundary
after paying the toll so can i compute
uh my ring road geodesic between these
two generalized probability measures row
zero and row one
so
clearly this is a one dimensional
problem so everything will take place
along this one dimensional segments
capital i joining the two positions x0
and x1
and clearly also
the answer cannot be simply a traveling
direct delta
because this would have an infinite cost
somehow it's very easy to convince
yourself if you look essentially because
the reaction rate is quadratic in time
so you cannot you know suddenly
turn a blue car into a red car
instantaneously you cannot do that this
is forbidden by the model
so here's the theorem
so i will come in very briefly on the
numerology but it doesn't really matter
so
kappa is my total parameter which is
fixed
so the first thing you do is you compute
this magical exponent alpha
and then
you have an explicit formula
the explicit formula doesn't matter so
much for now uh what but what's more
interesting for me right now is actually
the expression of the of the geodesic
between those two direct deltas
so
it's not probably very easy to see just
looking at this formula the one thing
which is interesting is that i have now
an indicator function
so little r is the the one dimensional
variable along this segment the
one-dimensional segment in the previous
picture
so
rather than formulas let me draw
pictures so here is row zero direct
delta zero and you want to transfer
one red car inside the city to a blue
car on the road
and what the formula here tells is that
the optimal way to do that is the
following
so you start from one car
in the city and then
you start moving
you start moving and you see here the
blue mass let me rewind the blue mass is
kind of growing in time right the gamma
t increasing it increases over time and
what happens is that you see blue cars
driving according to this velocity field
here they drive they drive their drive
and whenever they hit the roads they
pair the tow they transform into blue
cars and this contributes to growing the
total amount of blue cars
okay
and
one thing i want you to notice is that
this picture is say at time t equals 10
to the minus nine
seconds
so almost instantaneously cars
the red cars who started at x equals
zero at time zero
instantaneously travel all the way to
the boundary
okay
and this does not happen in classical
optimal transfer this is very different
somehow
the second thing i want to mention which
is it's very easy to check
since i have this explicit formula the
first thing which i can check is that
as kappa goes to zero
here
the real world distance uh converges to
one half of the squared distance between
the direct deltas which should remind
you of something
and the second observation i want to
make is that as the total cost goes to
plus infinity the cost blows up
uh so let me skip the idea of proof uh i
just want to
you know discuss a little more about
this uh geometrical property don't worry
it's almost the last slide i know the
time is over um
but what one can prove is that the real
distance can be sandwiched in between
two quantities
the first one is that you can lower
bound the ringworm distance by the
squared vases and distance
between the total effective densities so
these are the calligraphic rows
which is just the sum of blue cars plus
red cars regardless of their colors
right i just forget about the colors
so this is the first lower bound i can
give on the on the ring road distance
the upper bound i can give
is um
the sum of two squared version distance
the first one is the square vasculation
distance in the city between blue cars
plus the faster shine distance of the
red cars on the road
and moreover um
there is conversions in this distance if
and only if
those two measures converge separately
which is very nice for applications
a quick comment is that let me remind
you that this quantity here in the
middle my ringworld distance is
increasing in kappa
and those inequalities are actually
sharp
so you can saturate those inequalities
and i could i can also cook up counter
examples where the inequalities are
sharp
so the last question i want to address
today and this is going to be very quick
is
of course what happens in the small town
limit when kappa goes to zero and in the
large total limit when kappa goes to
plus infinity
right
and here is the answer
so when kappa goes to zero
the real world distance converges
to the fastest and distance between the
effective density
right so again row calligraphic is just
the sum of blue cars plus red cars
and as kappa goes to plus infinity
the
ring real distance converges to the sum
of two independent optimal transport
vessels distances
and this intuitively is very clear why
because when kappa goes to zero what
you're saying is that it's
you can move from the city to the
highway for free
right
so if i can do that for free there's no
reason anymore to distinguish colors
right the only thing i need to keep
track is how many cars there are around
me regardless of blue or red
and this is what the first
conclusion of the theorem 6 exactly
likewise
as kappa goes to plus infinity the toll
becomes infinitely expensive and
therefore in the limits you're kind of
forbidden
to transfer blue cards into red cards
whatever was blue cars in the beginning
should remain blue cars forever
and same for the red cars meaning that
uh you're kind of
completely shutting down the interaction
between the bulk and the interface
and again this is exactly what this
theorem says
moreover the minimizers also converge so
i didn't phrase it here in terms of
gamma conversions but this is a possible
way of formulating the result
and maybe just a few words on
perspectives the first question i want
to address is i would like to
investigate is is there a static
formulation of this problem it's not
clear to me
the second one which is a very natural
step is write down gradient flows and
you know parabolic evolution pdes
the third thing i would like to do is a
dynamical
evolution of interfaces and i think
clement consists and bernoulli are
looking into this but i'm not completely
sure
another possible direction would be
considering more complex structures like
you know
the road does not have to be the
boundary of the domain it could be a
fractal
you know d minus two dimensional
structure within the city i don't know
something like that
and uh something we're also looking into
with the tomah galway and maxine labord
is numerix for this is this robust
enough to give numerics and the answer
is partially yes and partially
so with that i will finish my apologies
for being late and thank you for your
attention
so everyone in the audience you can
ask the question directly for from
and for zoom
you can uh speed up if you want you can
uh
open up your microphone and say
something or write uh the question
so are there any questions here
that's my phone
thank you very much for a very inspiring
talk uh if you could go back to
i think slide
11
which one sorry the audio is like
i think 11 or 10 where you have a of
oh uh
[Music]
uh
this one
correct yes right right ah perfect now
we're here fine um so
there is a little bit of a symmetry in
terms of you have the interior of the
domain they have your boundary domain
and then in the in the functional
the the f and the gamma they have the
same support so you have you can have
the ratio f square of a gamma
a so i'm wondering like
suppose the the red and the blue were
interfacing through a boundary
but
the red was not the boundary
yes
yes so actually so this is mentioned in
the perspective i didn't discuss it very
much but so oh maybe i misunderstood a
question but one thing which is a very
natural to do is uh somehow the flux
is completely symmetric so little f i
can see either as the influx of uh
of red cars or the outflux of blue cars
is
the equivalent however why should i wait
this flux with respect to the density of
cars on the roads rather than density of
cars on the on the city it's not clear
yes and the the the tricky
part for that is that um
in this thing so obviously you know f
only lives on the boundary of the domain
omega
what so what is little omega here should
it be like the boundary trace of a
continuous density omega think of omega
as an absolutely continuous measure
should the nega be the trace of the
absolute continuous part of omega inside
the domain or should omega here be you
know omega could be an absolute
continuous part on the domain plus a
singular term on the boundary it's not
completely clear
so one way to possibly do that is you
know thicken a little the
do an absolute boundary layer and allow
the two to interact in the middle
and yes this is a very natural question
i i completely agree with you and this
is what i mean by more complex
structures in some sense this is the
third model to start with and
more possible and complicated
interaction should be doable yes
and this would be more so the pressing
if if the red
and the blue
are interfacing through a common
boundary but they're not the boundary
one is not the boundary the other yes
exactly yeah yeah this
i don't know that's so that's a good
question that's something i have in my
mind but i haven't started you know sit
down and looked into it but yeah this is
very natural indeed thank you very much
sure
you have time for another short question
um
so
in the motivation you've got the street
at the edge of the city where usually
you can drive a lot faster than in the
city and so you would probably rate the
boundary term differently
which i imagine doesn't change the
mathematics too much but does it affect
the geodesics
uh no so that's a very good question so
that's actually one of the purposes one
of the reasons why i wanted to to do
numerix so uh it doesn't change the
mathematics so much
as far as uh fixed all is concerned so
if you fix kappa in my model indeed what
you can do is uh you know wait
differently typically your rights like
if you drive on a highway it's much more
efficient therefore it's it's most
efficient
under on the highway and and this you
can do so you can include an extra
parameter that in our numerics we call
delta for some reason
this you can do however this changes
drastically uh the
the limit kappa goes to zero or kappa
goes to plus infinity
and the
now it's kind of not completely let me
give you one example so assume it's
almost free to travel on the on the
highway like you're allowed to drive a
quadzillion miles an hour on the highway
if you have a city which is a let me use
an illustration will be here more
convenient
if you're here
and you want to go there
right
it's a relative ratio between how much
the toll costs and how much how fast you
can drive on the highway so for example
so if it's extremely cheap to travel
very fast on the on the road what might
be uh the optimal value is you first
drive as fast as possible to the highway
play your fixed all like one dollar you
enter the highway and then you travel
along the highway extremely fast almost
instantaneously
and then
exit back here
right
and the relative ratio of delta so the
parameter saying how fast you're allowed
to drive on the highway with respect to
how much you have to pay
for the total fee
really matters because this scenario
that i just described is far from being
optimal if instead of paying one buck
for the toffee you have to pay a million
dollars right you don't want to do that
anymore
so you see that
it's a delicate balance between the two
and that's exactly why i want marriage i
want to you know play with these two
parameters simultaneously
but yes this is a very natural question
this is you can imagine much more uh
yeah more general scenarios indeed
the question or
i think we are all the time
yeah yeah sorry about that my fault
it was very interesting so thank you
switch immediately thank you leonard
again and let's switch
to
zapper
so can you put this live